recueillement au temple taoïste pour
chier mais moi et son copain
des prières pour honorer la mémoire de
l'enfant qu'ils ont choisi de ne pas
avoir
les circonstances ne le permettait pas
le jeune couple a pris la délicate
décision de subir un avortement légal
par prise de médicaments
taïwan est un des endroits les plus
progressistes en asie un peu moins de
30000 avortements légaux seraient
pratiquées annuellement sur l'île de 24
millions d'habitants
les dernières années ont vu une
augmentation du nombre de femmes
demandant des conseils ou de l'aide
psychologique en lien avec les
avortements en vertu de la loi sur la
santé génétique à taïwan les femmes
mariées doivent obtenir le consentement
de leurs conjoints afin d'avoir accès à
l'avortement lit mineur elles doivent
fournir l'approbation de leurs parents
ou de leur gardien légaux une réflexion
est en cours depuis quelques années et
des amendements pour élargir l'accès à
l'avortement pourrait être présenté
bientôt
beaucoup de femmes réclament de l'aide
car leur mariage et violent ou bien car
elle voulait déjà un divorce à voir la
grossesse explique t-elle alors comment
est ce possible d'obtenir la permission
du conjoint pour un avortement dans de
telles conditions
une statuette pour chaque grossesse
interrompu que ce soit volontairement ou
non l'influencent religieuses demeure
très forte à taïwan selon les temples
taoïstes et bouddhiste il faut demander
pardon pendant trois ans à l'esprit de
l'enfant qui n'a pas vu le jour
les couples viennent à la recherche de
l'harmonie perdu explique-t-il
chez minois et son copain entament leur
séjour spirituelle pour se libérer de
leur sentiment de culpabilité
l'avortement demeure souvent tabou
personnes de leur entourage n'est
d'ailleurs au courant
c'est vrai elle a peur de la réaction de
sa famille et de ses amis
l'accès à l'avortement pourrait être
élargie prochainement à taiwan mais
l'acceptabilité sociale la plus grande
échelle demeure un tout autre débat ici
philippe leblanc radio-canada miaoli à
taïwan